one tree hill star bevin prince's
husband william friend is dead after
being struck by lightning he was 33
years old north carolina news station
wect 6 reports that authorities
discovered william on a boat during a
storm off the coast of wilmington after
he had been struck the outlet also
reports that the new hanover county
sheriff's office along with wilmington
police department's marine unit
responded to the scene after
eyewitnesses flagged them down deputies
performed cpr on william before taking
him to the marina for emergency medical
attention ems moved him to an ambulance
where they attempted to resuscitate him
for 20 minutes but he was pronounced
dead on the scene
following the tragic incident bevin's
best friend actress odette annable paid
tribute to william on instagram
alongside photos of him with his wife
she wrote
will it feel surreal writing this mostly
because it feels like you were just
getting started the life and love that
you gave to my best friend made it feel
okay that we were thousands of miles
apart odette went on to talk about the
gift he gave to everyone who got to
witness the passion that burned in his
soul she also shared a gofundme link
benefiting two causes william felt
strongly about in lieu of flowers one
including the business he started with
his wife a cycling gym where she now
works as a fitness trainer
bevin first rose to fame with her role
as bevin mursky on one tree hill in
2004. i just let you and the other girls
out of your way because that's how you
need it to be
and i think carl's right pretty soon
we're all gonna graduate and
i can start over
and we've had a lot of success it's been
great amazing cast amazing people too
much fun flash forward a decade to may
2016 and the actress and william tied
the knot
the two later moved to wrightsville
beach north carolina to be closer to
family during the coven 19 pandemic
bevin has yet to speak out about her
husband's death
you